the double murder trial of Alex Murdock
is underway and today the first witness
will take the stand in the case
prosecutors say the one's prominent
lawyer killed his wife and 22 year old
son to distract from Financial crimes
that were about to come to light he has
since been charged with nearly 100 such
crimes including stealing more than 8
million dollars Nikki Batiste has been
covering this case from the very
beginning she's outside the courthouse
it's in Walterboro South Carolina Nikki
good morning to you
Gail good morning a jury of eight women
and four men listen to about an hour of
opening arguments here yesterday when I
first sat in a courtroom with Alex
Murdoch in 2021 he looked like a broken
man shaking and in shackles with his
head bowed now he looks a lot like the
Poise lawyer he once was
appearing calm and confident Alex
Murdoch listened closely to opening
arguments in his double murder trial as
the lead prosecutor called the crimes a
perfect storm of desperation a key piece
of forensic evidence that you're going
to hear in this case
he told the jury cell phone evidence
places Murdoch at the family's estate
within minutes of when his wife Maggie
and 22 year old son Paul were shot to
death at close range Murdoch has always
denied he was there claiming at the time
he was visiting his mother the
prosecution also argued that bullet
casings found by Maggie's body match a
firearm Murdoch owned which is now
missing it was a family weapon that
killed Maggie the defense fired back he
didn't do it he didn't kill butcher his
son and wife Murdoch's lawyer dick
harputlian says there's zero evidence
his client committed the murders they
decided
that night
he did it
without forensics without cell phones
without any of that Murdoch became
emotional as his attorney detailed
Paul's gruesome death harputley and also
told the jury Murdoch had no reason to
kill the wife and child he loved why
this is going to be interesting
because we don't know why he doesn't
know why but local reporter Michael
DeWitt who has covered the case from day
one says the prosecution does have a
motive for the murders they believe the
motive was to distract from his
nearly 100 Financial crimes so they
believed that he committed this drastic
violent act to gain sympathy to buy time
and to distract people and just for a
little while it worked in a nearly
packed courtroom Murdoch's sister
brothers and surviving son Buster sat
two rows behind him do you think your
dad's guilty or innocent
about your dad
the first witness to take the stand
today will be a first responder to the
crime scene jurors will be shown about
45 minutes of his body camera video
showing Alex Murdoch's Behavior after he
says he found his wife and son and
called 9-1-1 Murdoch has pleaded not
guilty to the murders if convicted Gale
he faces life in prison
some of the details of this case still
so hard to believe but a lot of people
are watching thank you very much Nikki